so today we're gonna talk about social
insurance so why do we have this thing
called social insurance let's first talk
about what social insurance is and then
ask why we have it okay so basically
social insurance is government provided
insurance programs this is the largest
single category of government
expenditure in the u.s. today is
government provided insurance programs
now why do we have these well you might
say well we know I have these we learned
about uncertainty we already talked
about how people dislike uncertainty and
about how as a result insurance is big
business in America private insurance
for health for auto for life for
property and casualty adds up to about
1.5 trillion dollars every year okay so
we already have big business of private
insurance so why is the government need
to get involved I mean after all people
want insurance if they're risk-averse we
talked about insurance markets can work
and as always at economics the question
is what's wrong with the private market
what is the market failure that might
generate interest in government being
involved and the market failure in the
context of insurance is a different kind
of market rather we've talked about
we've talked about market failures like
imperfect competition as a market
failure we talked about externalities as
a market failure the new kind of market
oh you want to talk about today is what
we call information asymmetry
information asymmetry okay basically
which is the difference in the
information available to sellers and to
buyers in a given market so far in this
course we sort of assumed full
information we've assumed everybody
knows everything we weaken that
assumption a little bit with uncertainty
and saying that people don't know
whether they're gonna be sick or healthy
but they still knew the probabilities
now really get it further by saying he
now knows the information imperfect but
different parties in a transaction might
have different levels of information and
that's going to turn out to cause market
failure that information asymmetry will
cause market failure now the math here
is quite hard harder than we do in this
class so we'll just sort of do this by
an example or two and the best example
to start with is the so-called lemons
problem that was laid out by the Nobel
prize-winning economist George Akerlof
in 1970 Nobel Prize of economists and a
husband of former Fed Chairman Janet
Yellen quite a power couple and um
here's what acryl off laid out he said
let's look at the market for used cars
so this tomorrow for used cars as of
1970 there was no CARFAX
there was none as information ok 97 when
to buy a used car just sort of went and
kicked the tires and decide if you're
gonna buy it ok so this is a classic
case of an information asymmetry in that
someone selling a car knows what's wrong
with it
where's the person buying the car
doesn't okay I'll go illegally would
sort of kick the tires and hope for the
best okay we don't so basically um and
in particular sellers of cars might be
selling them because they're not good
after all why sell a car maybe because
it's what's called a lemon a lemon is
something which is a poorly performing
product in this case a car that's got
something wrong with it so when you go
to buy a car you're worried you want to
buy a car in the used car market but
you're worried why is someone selling
this car you should be why is someone
selling this car if it's really in good
shape why would they be selling it
therefore as a result Akerlof argued
there might be a collapse of the entire
used car market there might not be
transactions that happen they can make
both parties better off remember a
market failure is whenever the private
market fails to maximize welfare what
that means is a market failure arises
whatever the private market
does not deliver all transactions that
make buyer and seller better off okay
and here and so let's look an example
this suppose that I have a ten-year-old
car and I keep it in pristine shape hint
that's not true for me I'm terrible of
course but imagine I was someone who
wasn't I kept my ten-year-old car in
pristine shape and let's say that a
ten-year-old car in pristine shape is um
and let's say I'm trying to sell this
car and let's say that I would happily
take $5,000 for this ten-year-old car
that's in pristine shape so I would be
willing to sell at 5k and let's say that
you let's say Patricia
needs that used car and she is willing
to buy a car that's in good shape for 6k
so my willingness to willingness to
provide willingness to supply is 5k her
willingness to pay is 6 K so that is a
transaction that should happen given the
quality of my car given this in good
shape she is willing to pay a thousand
dollars more than I'm willing to sell it
for such transaction should happen it'll
be welfare maximizing but let's say that
most ten-year-old cars are not in good
shape
most ten-year-old cars in fact are in
kind of crappy shape and in fact the for
the typical ten-year-old car to get it
up and running well you'd have to throw
$2,000 in once you bought it and
Patricia knows this she knows that for
the typical ten-year-old car she would
have to put two thousand dollars in so
her willingness to pay is not 6 K its
Forte for an average ten-year-old car
now I see the Patricia well that's an
average ten-year-old car but I have a
perfect ten-year-old car you don't need
to put 2 K into it it's good to go so
why don't we split the difference will
play 55 K and she says no way you're a
damn liar I have no way of knowing your
car is better than average all I know is
the average ten-year-old car needs
$2,000 of work so I'm not gonna pay more
than 4
thousand dollars for your car as the
result Patricia doesn't buy my car and a
transaction that would have made both
parties better off does not happen a
transaction where if there was full
information like we have much more of
today where you can get the entire
record of the car all the crash that's
been in how much carrots taken care of
that problem would go away should go
away because now pictures you could look
at my car fax and note this is this in
fact is a pristine car and she's more
willing to pay the six thousand for it
but the bottom line is in this world of
1970 this was a market failure because
they transaction that made both parties
better off did not happen because of
imperfect information okay
the buyer was perfectly happy to buy
Patricia is perfectly happy to buy my
car but because I had information than
she didn't and she was suspicious that I
was lying
as a result that transaction didn't
happen now questions about that people
understand it's a market failure okay
now we come to insurance the story is
flipped now it's not the seller that has
the information
it's the buyer that has the information
in particular when you buy insurance you
know how healthy you are you know your
genetic history you know whether you're
a risk taker you know whether you're
around a lot of snotty kids who might
get you sick you know a lot of stuff
about yourself that the insurer doesn't
know as a result the information
asymmetry is flipped with insurance the
insurer is worried that when you come
looking for insurance they're worried
looking for insurance because you're
sick now you might be looking for sure
it's cuz you're risk-averse and that's
great for insurers we talked about
insurance how there's essentially a gain
I'm willing to pay a risk premium so
insurers can make money by selling to me
but what if I'm not coming to you I'm
risk averse whatever I'm coming because
I'm a huge skydiving fan okay and you
don't know that you might be afraid to
sell me insurance because you might lose
money on me
okay so let's work out another example
to show this imagine you graduate and
you decide a great business model is to
offer health insurance to recent MIT
grads
you say look we're a bunch of kind of
careful nerds we're like not going to go
skydiving we're like just gonna sit our
desks and work maybe there'll be carpal
tunnel risk but other than that we're
pretty safe bunch so I'm going out for
health insurance a recent MIT grads
because they're a healthy group and
let's say suppose that of every hundred
MIT grads 90 are healthy and 10 are
sickly let's just suppose you know those
facts you know those facts you've
collected the data to know that on
average of every hovering hundred grads
nine you're healthy ten or sickly you
don't know which are which but you know
the proportions and let's say that with
a healthy person over the next year
there's a 10% chance that they will need
that they will encourage that they will
incur a $10,000 charge and a 90% chance
that they will 90% chance that they'll
have zero costs okay so there's a 10%
chance fall of a ten thousand dollar
costs knives a chisel of a zero cost
okay so your expected cost for assuring
this person is one thousand dollars you
expect someone like that will cost you
$1,000 now suppose for the sickly guy
there's a 50% chance 50% chance that
they'll cost you 10 K and a 50% chance
that they'll cost you zero so you
expected costs for them or the expected
cost for this person is $5000 okay do
people understand the setup there's two
types I know
these facts but I don't know who's who I
just know these facts okay because I'm
good at math I've done all the actuarial
calculations okay
if everyone buys and now I'm gonna set
my price well I'm gonna do the price I'm
going to say look if everyone by is
health insurance then I've got my
expected cost is 0.9 times a thousand
plus 0.1 times 5000 my expected cost is
1,400 so I expect to have to spend
fourteen hundred a year in fact on
average I'll spend fourteen hundred a
year okay with large enough samples I
can predict that with certainty that if
everyone buys insurance I'll spend
fourteen hundred dollars a year so let's
say you're risk neutral because you're
rich and so for 200 you know this is
sort of risk neutral for you so you say
look I'll just charge I'll set a premium
of 1500 and I'll make a hundred dollars
per person if a hundred will buy that's
$10,000 profit that's pretty good okay
there are thousand kids in a graduating
class
it's a thousand kids buy and I make
hundreds profit it's at the hundred
thousand that's pretty good money for a
year okay now what is wrong with this
calculation what in fact will happen if
you sell insurance for fifteen hundred
dollars
yeah well let's go step by step what
about sick people if you sell fifteen
hundred dollars what will they do yes so
if you set up fifty hundred dollars you
are certainly going to sell to all the
sick okay so if you sell for fifteen
hundred dollars you'll certainly sell to
all the sick what about the healthy what
will determine whether or not they buy
yeah
not quite not quite there's another
piece too don't forget what else what
else what else is not just expected cost
what else version remember there's a
risk premium that they'll pay so whether
that's healthy person will buy or not
you just expected cost then they
wouldn't buy it's a thousand dollars
expected cost while the 1500 but some
might be risk-averse and buy so let's
say let's just say half the guys are
risk averse and they they're willing to
pay 1500 for $1,000 expected cost and a
half arm so let's say you end up selling
to all the sick and half the healthy
okay
so how much money do you make well you
make you sell with 60 people at $1,500
each so your revenues are $75,000 right
you sell 250 healthy intense ik7 $5,000
Remy's what are your costs your costs
are you have 10 people that are cost you
five thousand so it's 50 thousand plus
50 people are going to cost you a
thousand plus another 50 thousand equals
one hundred thousand dollars and you've
lost money you priced at above the
expected total and lost money why did
you lose money you lost money because of
the problem of adverse selection the
problem of we call adverse selection
adverse selection is the problem that
due to information asymmetries only the
worst risks will participate in the
market and that will cost people selling
in the market to lose money or likewise
here the concern is that only the only
the worst cars will put his fate in the
market and so the people buy cars will
be worse off yeah
we can make know you sell to you sell
1500 each and you sell to uh yes you're
right you'd make ninety thousand my bad
yes fifteen hundred each time sixty
people's ninety thousand he still lose
money but not as much right okay now
there's no you might say look you're not
losing that much easy solution just
raise the price right what if he said
fine let's just raise the price and
let's charge two thousand dollars a
person then that would cover right
because two thousand dollars a person
six who will make one hundred and twenty
thousand the costs are a hundred
thousand you'd be golden right yeah who
would you lose not the sick the sick are
delighted by ten thousand but once you
raise the price more healthy people drop
out because it's higher than the risk
premium so what happens is by raising
the price you necessarily make money it
depends on how many healthy people drop
out so for example imagine that you
raise it to two thousand dollars but now
the number of healthy people that buys
drops to 20 from fifty then you lose
money again so the point is you can
actually solve this problem just by
raising the price because there's this
what we call death spiral does this term
of call a death spiral which is as you
raise the price you chase out the
healthier people which means you have to
raise the price more which shakes out
even healthier even more healthy people
and you end up in this death spiral okay
so that is the problem of that is the
problem of adverse selection and that
leads you to say you know what I'm not
going to offer this product I can't make
money on it because what if I set the
price um whatever price I said I'm gonna
lose money so I'm not gonna offer the
product therefore the market has failed
a market that might have existed on
average this was a market that made
people better off but the market that
might have existed doesn't does it exist
yeah
right so if you leave this alone that's
an excellent point
watch what should the new equilibrium be
the price brow should continue to you've
chased all the healthy people out and
then you price but you'd have to price
it then at what five thousand plus
something so as long as sickly people or
risk-averse you could still make money
you can still make money if you sold say
fifty five hundred with even modest risk
aversion why is that still a market
failure well because there's there's all
these healthy people who now can't get
health insurance okay so yes it doesn't
mean the market collapses market
failures in this looming market collapse
it means a reduction in welfare because
transactions that might make some people
better off on happening here you might
be able to offer insurance for healthy
will that makes them better off but
you're not you're only offering
insurance for the sick so it's a market
failure because healthy people who might
want the insurance end up being kept out
of the market by ever selection okay
questions about that and that is the
fundamental market failure we face an
insurance market that's why we think
private insurance markets will not
function well because private insurers
in some sense the fundamental problem is
that you're setting one price one price
for multiple products the great case of
average selection is going to buy fruit
at the beginning versus the end of the
day what's the difference buy fruit to
begin the end of the day yeah I don't
buy a lot of fruit but try to think
about it yeah what's left is left
because you'll check one price you
didn't say good apples a dollar at
eighty shitty apples a dollar forty you
said apples one seventy so people come
and they buy apples they they go and
they feel it you know and they feel
around they find the good ones the ones
that left or crack okay and that is the
adverse selection problem now with
apples the markets
exist why because they charge so much
they can live with a few bad apples
being at the bottom so to speak a few
bad apples being at the bottom with
health insurance if I get one bad risk
someone say who's really really sick and
cost a million dollars I go out of
business so adverse selection may not
destroy markets that doesn't destroy the
apple market but it can destroy or
significantly impede insurance markets
okay questions about that yeah we'll
talk about that next lecture we talk
about health care
so that's separate about the cost of
health care this is a reason why
insurance companies make you felt a lot
of forms before you go in so it's for
this reason insurance companies are not
powerless against this problem they
could try to collect as much information
about you as they can as I get more and
more information can learn more and more
who's healthy who's sick then I can
solve this problem
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah so is it possible so this
is a great point it's for next time I'll
talk about it now
which is in some sense we are eventually
moving to a point with OB no adverse
selection now you might say in the one
hand that's because último menteur born
right well no your genes
well no it's good now we won't know if
you're a skydiver but well no no
probably no genes to determine risk
taking and we'll charge more for people
like taking risks
so the doubt the good news is that then
I can I can make the market work the bad
news is in that world how would I set my
insurance prices I would charge because
what I would do is I'd say your genes
say you're healthy so I want 1,100 bucks
from you your genes say you're sick so I
want six thousand dollars from you
so essentially insurance wouldn't exist
anymore
there'd be no insurance what is
insurance insurance is pooling people
with different probabilities of adverse
events and letting us all benefit for
the fact that if it happens to us at
least we're protected well if you charge
me my expected cost I'm no longer
protected so here's the example that
makes it perfectly clear one of the most
famous examples Ken arrow is one of the
great economists the 20th century died
recently he had his famous Islands
example ken arrows Islands examples the
following a measures to island somewhere
in the South Pacific that are very small
that's got one farmer on each and the
farmers know a hurricane is coming and
it's gonna wipe out one of their islands
but they don't know which there's no
one's gonna get wiped out what will they
naturally do they'll naturally get
together and say look I'll just get it
wiped out but let's ensure each other
if I get wiped out you give me a bunch
of your crop if you get why
are you into my crop that will improve
both our welfare right because getting
wiped out is going to zero you die
that's a terrible outcome so that will
improve our welfare if we insure each
other now let's say a weather service
comes along and provides information and
tells you that farmer aids island is
getting wiped out in farmer B's islands
gonna be fine what has happened to
welfare it's gotten worse
why because farmer a goes far beats it
turns out a new wipeout farm B says welp
see ya I'm just gonna keep consuming my
high level farmer B is somewhat better
off farmer a is dead okay total social
welfare has fallen because the concavity
because of diminishing marginal 'ti more
information has made us worse we say is
more is better in economics once you get
topics like this you realize more is not
always better more is worse more
information has destroyed the insurance
market that might function so in fact
this issue I'm talking about is becoming
paramount as we move more and more
towards perfect information environment
okay so the kind of government Paul sim
talk about next become critical as you
move towards that environment but first
I wanna make sure we lunched into the
front why the private markets failed why
it's a failure okay now what can the
government do about this what are some
potential government solutions and we've
tried all these in the US and around the
world let's talk about three categories
of government solutions the first is
subsidization the government could
subsidize the purchase of health
insurance so for example what if the US
government said to all the MIT grads I
am gonna give you a $400 tax credit that
you can have if or 500 credit if you buy
health insurance well if there's a $5
verified by health insurance then what's
and I charge $1,500 then what's the
effective priced out of the healthy guy
a thousand so he buys even if he's risk
neutrally by its long as he's a tiny bit
risk-averse so I do sell to everyone and
I make my money so one way to solve this
problem is to basically pay to help
people to get into the market they can
seek the help money to help you
give it to everyone because you can't
tell it was healthy but if you give
everyone a tax credit then we can bring
everyone into the market and solve this
problem well in fact we do this in
America it's actually perhaps the
largest hidden government expenditure in
our country which is the tax subsidy to
employer sponsored insurance employer
health insurance attack subs employer
health insurance what I mean by that
what a means of following when MIT pays
me in wages I am taxed on that like the
taxation we talked about a couple
lectures ago when MIT pays me and health
insurance I am not taxed on that so what
does that mean so if MIT comes to me
they say would you like $1,000 race or
$1,000 orthodontia benefits for your
daughter
I say well thousand all the Rays of
today's tax rates I'm gonna take home
about 550 if you add up all the taxes
I'll pay and I'll take them about 550
okay
thousand I also don't understand
benefits my daughter I get the whole
thousand so why not so I got these cool
braces they spin and change color and
every two weeks she's in four different
kind of braces it's great cuz it's free
okay so we do subsidize health insurance
in America and this amounts to this
program that I just talked about amounts
to almost 300 billion dollars per year
we spent almost 300 billion dollars per
year giving a tax break to people to buy
health insurance okay so that's one
tactic we take to try to solve this
problem to get health people into the
market
that's approach one a second approach
one can use to try to get people into
the market is a mandate suppose I just
pass a law that says everyone has to buy
health insurance well then I've solved
the problem right I know what my
expected costs are if everyone has to
buy I know my expected costs are 1,400
so I know I can make money at 1500 well
that's easier one level well they don't
have to I don't have to spend I don't
just spend three billion dollars a lot
of money this cost me zero it's harder
another level why what's the problem
with that solution yeah
well it may not may not have it that's
right
what else yeah people are gonna be
pissed
they're like look if I had chosen not
you're gonna basically the mandate only
has an effect if it changes people's
behavior but chases the behavior you
mean you're making them do something I
didn't want to do beforehand so the
problem with that the problem with this
is you spend a lot of money problem of
this you piss off healthy people okay
the third approach we could do okay and
there's lots of examples of the mandate
obviously we know about the health
insurance mandate that was originally
part of Obamacare but that's not the
biggest example the biggest example in
the u.s. is what's called workers comp
insurance which is insurance that you
have for on-the-job injuries if you get
hurt at work your employer pays money so
that you get reimbursed when you when
your it pays your medical bills when you
hurt working gives you partial
replacement of your wages that is
mandated insurance on all employers in
America except in Texas Texas they can
choose every other state it's mandated
mandated insures that we employ in
America they have to buy workers comp so
we have examples of that and that's at
eighty billion dollar a year program
that's a big deal
finally we could just provide the
insurance that's actually the most
common thing we do in America
Social Security is our program that
provides insurance for the elderly for
therefore the costs for survival after
retirement Medicare is insurance for the
elderly we provide unemployment
insurance is that sure as we ride
against losing your job disability
insurance is insurance we provide
against having a career-ending
disability so this is actually the most
common thing indeed provision of social
insurance in America costs almost costs
more than private insurance so we spent
about a trillion and a half on private
insurance in America
social insurance is probably one point
seven to two trillion depending how you
measure it so actually this is the
biggest thing we do is we just provide
insurance okay
and that is um and that's a very large
that that's a very large solution now
once again what's the problem with this
well you don't make that B help people
unhappy because everyone you just give
it to them the problem is you have to
spend money on this this is one point
seven trillion dollars in taxes we've
got to raise every year that's that's
non-trivial okay so basically each of
these solutions has potential problems
so the adverse selection problem will
cause a private market to fail there are
potential government solutions but each
have limitations this one's pretty
expensive
this one's super expensive this one
pisses off healthy people okay now
you'll note the middle one the pissed
off fella feels kind of subtle you don't
see a lot of health people railing
against mandated version of workers comp
like bid against the health insurance
mandate because people don't know okay
so it's up says this one's a little bit
subtle okay because people have to know
that you're you know basically it's sort
of crazy that I'm paying taxes every I'm
never getting hurt at work am I gonna
have one I gonna like slip in my desk or
something never gonna hurt at work but I
pay taxes all the time just in case
someone else at MIT gets hurt you know
so when the janitorial staff has a fit
as a risk of being hurt I'm paying taxes
in case the janitor gets hurt I should
be upset about that but I'm not and in
subsets it's about kind of what people
know what they don't okay so that is the
basic argument for social insurance but
would provide social insurance despite
all these problems we enter into a
fundamental trade-off which is let's
decide we've determined some optimal
government policy let's decide that the
markets failed so we're gonna do one of
these things and so if some kind of
she's in solve the problem the problem
is that when you insure people for risks
you create a new problem called moral
hazard moral hazard moral hazard is
basically the adverse behavior that is
encouraged by insurance when you insure
people you encourage adverse behavior so
the classic example this is
if I have health insurance I ride my
bike less carefully I guess by getting a
crash no I'm not crazy I still don't get
in a crash but I'm a little bit less
careful because I know I'm insured in
case I get in a crash if I have fire
insurance I don't buy a fire
extinguisher for my house because it
burns down I just could get the money
back anyway
or if workers have insurance against
losing a job that pays them without a
work they might search less hard for a
new job right basically if I lose my job
and I got nothing I'm gonna work my ass
off to get a new job if I lose my job
and the government says well for twenty
six weeks we'll give you half your
salary while you look for a job I'll be
a little bit less rushed okay the
problem and there's lots of evidence
that moral hazards the problem it comes
of two types of evidence the first type
of evidence is fun anecdotes so the
greatest best data to a workers
compensation let's take that workers
compensation
it's a program clothes needed lot of
people get hurt at work I don't but lots
of people do get hurt at work and so
it's a sensible social insurance program
the promise has a huge moral hazard
component and there's fun examples of
this like the the prison guard in
Massachusetts who claimed he got hurt on
the job collecting eighty-two thousand
dollars in benefits while the whole time
running a karate school and teaching
students karate and finally someone
noticed online this guy who couldn't
work was running in karate school and
doing karate kicks and stuff online so
there's all sorts of fun examples about
that but more convincing for economists
is statistical evidence and the
statistical evidence is clear that moral
hazards a big problem for example if you
raise the benefits people get under
workers comp suddenly they become
injured more often and stay at work
longer
there's no reason injuries should be
because you got hurt okay so how can it
be that suddenly when a state raises its
benefits suddenly as more injuries well
the answer is moral hazard when states
raise their unemployment insurance
benefits more people leave their jobs
and they stay unemployed longer moral
hazard so the moral has a problem is
real it's that inherent trade-off
actually not just the public insurance
private insurance - anytime you insure
people against something bad happens
you're providing less than incentive for
them to try themselves to avoid that bad
thing happening okay
so moral hazard is a real problem and
it's essentially the trade-off on the
one hand we talked about why people like
insurance weed locked about why people
like private insurance because of risk
aversion we talked about why government
intervention insurance markets is
necessary but that comes with a
trade-off which is the more insurance
you provide the less people will take
care of themselves and that's the
trade-off okay now why do we care let's
just sit back say okay that's like an
interesting Kannamma concept but why do
I care why don't I care if someone stays
out of work longer or fakes an injury or
whatever
why don't I care about this why is this
a problem well it's a problem for two
reasons well there's two costs to moral
hazard the first costume all hazard the
first costume all hazard is lower
efficiency and the best way to see this
is just to think about the economics of
the consumption leisure trade-off okay
think about how I make my decision of
how hard to work okay basically if
there's no insurance no social insurance
no workers comp no employee in sure ins
how do I choose how hard to work how do
I choose how hard to work how do I do
that what's a trade-off I consider in
deciding how hard to work yeah
assumption versus leisure in particular
I will mix trade them off until the
marginal value of the next hour of
leisure large Valley sure equals the
wage because the margin by Eve leisure
is above the wage I should work less
hard that means I'd rather be at home if
the marginalized leisure is below the
wage that means I'm just wasting my time
at home I should work harder so I'll
continue to trade off work and leisure
till the next hour of leisure makes me
just as happy as the next hour of
working okay and that is the efficient
outcome that is the social efficient
outcome because leisure is not a social
bad there's nothing wrong with leisure
okay people value leisure they should
get to trade
the leisure versus what they get from
working until they choose the right
amount that's what makes society best
off now what happens if I say well if
you sit at home you're also going to get
a check from the government well now
what's my new equation well now if I
work I still get the wage but what
happens if I sit at home I get the
marginal value of leisure plus the
government check so now I sit at home
until this equation is true which means
that I sit at home until the margin I of
leisure equals the wage minus the
government transfer that means the
moduli of leisure will be lower than it
would be without the government transfer
which means I work what more hard or
less hard if the marginal I of leisure
is forced down that means I'm doing what
so in return - yeah more leisure because
remember there's diminishing large of
ides of everything so I'm taking more
leisure less work so the government is
causing me to work less by essentially
saying look I'm gonna reward you more
for staying at home what does that do
that means that people work less than is
socially optimal this is the social
optimum this means people are taking
more leisure and working less than is
socially optimal when people work less
that shifts in the supply curve and
lower and creates a deadweight loss
social welfare has fallen let's be in
Portland let me remind you it's not
following because people take some time
off
okay many people on the conservative
side inspection will act as if work as a
virtue work is not a virtue okay the
optimal solution is to work until your
value of working equals a value of
leisure if you're someone who has a job
that you hate and doesn't pay well and
you love watching TV then you should
work less that's what the UH poem for
society but you shouldn't work even less
because the government's paying you to
stay home that produces efficiency so
that's the problem of moral hazard is it
lowers efficiency
there's a second problem of course of
moral hazard which is if you work less
then we have two taxable who do work
more to pay for these programs so it
raises taxation raises the required tax
revenues raises the tax revenues
required because if you're sitting at
home war I got to make more money to pay
for you to sit at home and we know
taxation also causes deadweight loss so
it's a double whammy I caused you to sit
at home and I caused other people have
to add more taxes to pay for you sit at
home which causes them to work less -
okay there's a second round effect as a
result moral hazard causes inefficiency
to society and that is the trade-off
once again I told you this course is
annoying we don't give you right answers
we tell you trade-offs the trade-off
here is we need programs like
unemployment insurance because otherwise
let's take the case of unemployment
shows there's one more time imagine is
no government unemployment insurance and
you said that's great I'll offer private
unemployment insurance well that's not
going to work why because people know
way more than you do about whether
they're gonna lose their job if you off
tried out for private insurance you'd
lose your shirt because of adverse
selection so absent government provided
unemployment insurance there would be no
unemployment insurance and that would be
bad that I mean people we subject to a
risk that would drive their consumption
of zero remember most Americans have no
savings that mean Americans will be
chubby too a risk where if they lost
their job they would starve that's a
very bad outcome so it is socially
valuable to insure against unemployment
risk the private market can't do it
because of adverse selection therefore
there is a compelling case for
government unemployment insurance but
will it provide unemployment insurance
it caused people to sit at home extra
and not work as hard and that's that's
the sort of chain of logic will teach
you the trade-off what this says is
optimal social insurance that in these
markets we're gonna want some social
insurance but not too much okay we're
gonna want enough to protect people
against starving but not so much that
cause people sit at home so for example
if I told you I'm a setup on
unemployment insurance program the way
it's gonna work is if you lose your job
I'm gonna pay your entire wage for as
long as you need until you find a new
job that would not be a good idea okay
that will cause a huge amount of moral
hazard and remember compare that compare
that program to one where I'll pay you
50 percent of your wage you find a new
job well 50 percent it's going from zero
to fifty is a zero of your wage to 50
your wage is a huge consumption
smoothing benefit you go from starving
to being able to eat decently 5,200 it's
an increase but not as much but 50-100
has a huge moral hazard effect so you
can want something more towards the
middle where you're getting people away
from starving but not so much that they
don't work okay so that's the trade-off
so let's talk about that trade-off in
practice let's talk about the u.s.
Social Security program the Social
Security program in the US okay
Social Security is our biggest single
social insurance program in the u.s.
it's currently currently the social
security progress about eight hundred
billion dollars per year that's real
money that's even one Jeff Bezos has
okay
eight hundred billion dollars a year
okay that's more than he's worth and
it's every year okay
what does this program do what this
program does in a nutshell is it ensures
you against the income loss you're gonna
face when you retire okay when people
retire they suddenly go from having a
lot of income to having no income and
basically the idea of Social Security is
to make sure you don't starve when
you're old so the way it works is you
pay a tax and if you ever see a line
your space that says FICA that's what
this is for you pay a fika tax it is
twelve point four percent of payroll
half on you and half on your employer
but it doesn't matter in half so
employer right because we learn Latin we
learn two lectures ago it doesn't matter
who pays the tax it's a twelve point
four percent tax that's what matters on
you okay that money then provides that
when you retire starting at age 62 you
get a check from the
government and you get a check from the
government that lasts until you die the
check from the government you get is
what's called an annuity an annuity is a
payment annuities are the opposite of
life insurance life insurance is money
that your family gets when you die
annuity is that it is a regular payment
you get until you die so the way it
works you pay twelve and a half percent
of your income all the way through your
working life then we turn 62 or you can
collect it later
um you then get a payment for the rest
of your life okay that payment is
typically about half of what you made
when you were working but it's very
progressive in the sense that for
someone who's very poor who has a very
poor it'll probably more than half of
what they made for someone who's rich to
be much less than half of what they made
it's a progressive payment everyone gets
it everyone did Social Security but how
much you get from it depends on your
income the poorer you are the more
generous it is relatively when you
retire
okay now the F yeah
that's that that's a huge problem it
sounds like you should definitely be
enrolled in 1441 that's a whole half of
lecture we spend on that I don't have
time to talk about here but clearly this
is a huge huge so just to give you a
couple numbers to keep you up at night
okay we all know we're all talking about
the deficit is 500 billion it's a big
deal okay if you add ask how much has
America promised to pay to our senior
citizens over the foreseeable future -
how much we'll collect in taxes we are
currently is the nation seventy five
trillion dollars in debt okay it's
because of the aging Society and things
like that
so we've got big problems coming down
the road we can talk about that another
time okay but let's focus on the program
itself at a point in time right now okay
so basically we see here the moral
hazard trade-off on the one hand we
don't be able to starve when they're old
on the other hand if I pay you once
you're retired that could cause you to
retire if I say once you're retired
you're gonna get a check 50 percent of
your wage you might say well if it's
your wage isn't that much but I really
don't like working in rather just hit
the links at 50% of my wage so that's
the trade-off okay now how do we think
about evaluating that trade-off well if
I don't that treadeth different
countries think about it differently in
the u.s. we think about it you know what
I would say is a fairly rational way
which is let's consider your decision to
retire at 62 vs. 63 the way works notice
we say look if Urich work one year more
since it's an annuity you will get one
less year of payment right if you start
at one year later you're gonna die the
same time you don't when you're less so
we do is we pay you more every month
indeed for every year you delay you get
6.7% more every month reflecting the
trade-off that you gonna get it for
shorter period of time and that turns
out to be roughly fair given the
expected life of Americans that's a
roughly fair trade-off okay every year
delay gets 6.7% more in Europe they
don't have this so every year you lay
you just get less money before you die
so let's take the example the
Netherlands in the Netherlands
you can retire 55 with a benefit that is
90% of what you mate
so if you were in $30,000 you can retire
55 for the benefit of $27,000 and if you
decide to work instead you just forego
that $27,000 there's no bump up of your
benefits that's just one last year of
$27,000 you get so what that means if
you're in the Netherlands your choices
work and get 30 or stay at home and get
27,000 in other words it's sort of like
a 90% tax think about it by working well
stay home I'm only keeping 3,000 or
30,000 I made it's basically like a 90
percent tax but that's not all how do
they pay for this program well they tax
people like Han tax people are home you
got tax workers so if you work you also
have to pay 45% tax to pay for this
program and lots of other things 45% tax
so you know it's a high tax rate for
everything what that means is if you
stay at home you get 27,000 if you go to
work you get 30,000 times 1.55 or about
our about 18,000 that's one by six one
it's sixteen five so your choices stay
at home and get 27 work and get sixteen
five guess what no one works no one over
55 Netherlands works like zero okay now
they might work on the black market and
wait their report to the government but
basically they just sort of sit around
coffee shops and spend their retirement
money okay so here's a case where
they've made a very different decision
on how to make this trade-off which is
you know it's a pretty sweet life for
the elderly in the Netherlands okay but
no one's working over age 55 and that's
a different way to resolve this
trade-off so basically this illustrates
different design features of the program
what makes the Netherlands program have
much more moral hazard than the u.s. if
their benefits are higher and they don't
increase your benefits if you work more
so essentially these are little kind of
TWiki details that turn out to matter
enormous lee probably think about the
program okay now Oh
that interesting that was a lot to put
in one lecture like I said he finds
interesting this is a whole third of
some third of a semester my class 1441
so take that we can learn a lot more
about it